Pycelle: Without question, Oldtown is the
oldest, wealthiest, and greatest city in Westeros.
Qyburn: Though King's Landing is more populous,
and arguably, more powerful.
Pycelle: The city straddles the mouth of the
Honeywine River, and the bounty of the entire
Reach flows beneath its stone bridges to ports
that are renowned throughout the world.
Qyburn: Thus, we needn't speak more of them.
More interesting is the history of the city,
for none can say when it was founded.
Many centuries ago, a few bold maesters sought
out the Children of the Forest, who claimed
that men have lived at the mouth of the Honeywine
since the Dawn Age.
Pycelle: Nonsense.
Maester Jellicoe proved that the city began
as a trading post where ships from Valyria,
Old Ghis, and the Summer Isles put in to replenish
their provisions and make repairs.
Hence, the most famous feature of the city,
the Hightower, raised even before the city
walls as a beacon through the fog-covered
waters.
Originally built of wood and standing a mere
fifty feet above the ancient fortress of its
foundation, it is now thick stone and rises
even taller than the Wall.
Those born and raised in Oldtown can tell
the time of day by where its shadow falls.
Qyburn: But no maester can tell why.
Even in our oldest records, the island on
which it stands is called Battle Isle.
What battle was fought there?
And when?
As for the ancient fortress that forms the
tower's base, its walls and interiors are
all of solid black stone with no hints of
joints.
Or mortar.
And no chisel marks of any kind.
We know it predates the tower itself by thousands
of years.
But who built it?
How?
And against what?
Pycelle: The maesters who have studied it
declare it to be of Valyrian construction,
akin to Dragonstone and the Black Walls of
Volantis.
As is well-known, the dragonlords of Valyria
could turn stone to liquid with dragonflame
to shape it as they wished.
Qyburn: Didn't one Archmaester link the fortress
to the vanished mazemakers of Lorath?
And another maester to the legendary Deep
Ones who inhabited the Iron Islands before
the Ironborn?
Pycelle: Both marginal opinions without common
support.
But of more importance than the origin of
the tower is the family to which it gave its
name.
House Hightower.The ancient ruling family
of Oldtown.Known for their prudence and love
of peace.
Qyburn: And pieces of gold.
Pycelle: During the Age of Heroes, when Lymond
Hightower saw the Gardener kings conquering
the Reach, he didn't beat them on the battlefield,
but in the godswood.
He bound his house to theirs by marriage.
And transformed House Hightower from wealthy
but relatively minor kings to the greatest
lords of the Reach.
Thanks to Lord Lymond's foresight, Highgarden
has always defended Oldtown, allowing the
Hightowers to focus on higher pursuits such
as learning and trade.
Qyburn: On that, we agree.
When the Andals invaded Westeros, Lord Dorian
Hightower told his wife of twenty years that
wars are bad for trade, and, to make his point,
traded her for a young Andal princess.
When Aegon the Conqueror was earning his name,
House Hightower traded its loyalty to the
Gardeners for his confirmation of their rights,
welcoming him with open arms and open gates.
Pycelle: House Hightower bent the knee to
Aegon to spare the city from his dragons.
I would think such insinuations and insults
beneath even you, Qyburn.
Then again, mockery of one's betters is the
trade of fools.
Qyburn: I wouldn't know.
Perhaps if I'd studied at the Citadel as long
as you, Grand Maester.
Pycelle: The Citadel is the greatest seat
of learning in the known world.
Without it, and the maesters it trains, Westeros
would be a land of superstition and ignorance.
Qyburn: Like the ignorance that shrouds the
Citadel's own birth?
Pycelle: Even without records, we have more
than enough reason to believe that the Citadel
began as a court of scholars and priests assembled
by a second son of House Hightower.
When he died, his elder brother raised the
Citadel so that wise men would always have
a home in Westeros and could continue the
inquiries and debates that had given such
joy to his younger brother.
Qyburn: His little brother's pets, as legend
has it, he called them.
And so the maesters have remained.
Only their masters have changed.
Now they serve every lord with a castle for
a fee, of course, whilst the Citadel serves
its own importance.
Pycelle: Every word you speak merely validates
your own expulsion from our ranks.
Qyburn: Knowledge is validation enough.
I assume the world's greatest minds would
agree.
And perhaps they would if I'd met them.
Oldtown is a city for old men and old beliefs.
Samwell Tarly: The Citadel of Oldtown is the
greatest center of learning in the world,
not that it has much competition, really.
Most lords think of books the way they think
of younger sons, useful to have around as
long as they keep to the corners.
Back when House Hightower still ruled Oldtown
as kings, a crippled younger son sought solace
in books and those who wrote them and became
the greatest patron of learning in his day.
Scholars of all sorts flocked to Oldtown to
debate and write and.
debate.
After this Prince Peremore's death, his brother
granted land to "Peremore's Pets," as the
wise men were called, though now they're known
as maesters.
Meera Reed: Mudmen.
Bog devils.
Those are just the most pleasant names our
fellow Northerners have for us, the crannogmen
who live in the swamps of the Neck.
Because we do not live in castles like them.Because
we do not farm like them.Because we are not
tall or rich like them.
But through our veins flows the same blood
of the First Men, and, at times, maybe something
more.
We still live much as they did, on floating
islands in houses of thatch and woven reeds.
We fish, hunt, and tell our children of our
heroes: the Knight of the Laughing Tree, who
fought in the Year of the False Spring; the
last Marsh King who challenged the Starks
and lost his crown and his daughter; and other
stories, older still, since lost to the world.
The Neck was not always a swamp.
In the Dawn Age, it was as dry and fertile
as the rest of the North.
But during the war with the First Men, the
Children of the Forest brought down the hammer
of the waters on the Neck, trying to break
Westeros in two.
When the waters finally receded, they left
the bogs and swamps we know today.
Many of the First Men decided to fight on,
but my ancestors wisely chose to heed the
Children's power and advance no further.
They beat their swords into frog-spears and
fish-hooks and settled a land forever devastated
by the folly of war.
Unlike the rest of Westeros, we keep no garrisons
and raise no soldiers for petty spats with
our neighbors.
Our land protects its own.
An outsider will find in the Neck an endless
morass of suckholes, quicksands, and green
grass that looks solid to the unwary eye but
turns to water the instant you treads on it.
If you are lucky enough to be armored, you
will only drown inside your own steel.
If you're not, you get to meet what swims
in that water: serpents, and monstrous lizard-lions
with teeth like daggers and never enough to
eat.
Don't worry.
Only your horse will live long enough to feel
their poisons burning through it.
If you somehow survive all this, you may find
that a well-placed dart can be as deadly as
any blade, not that you'll see us blowing
it your way.
Since the fall of the last Marsh King, House
Reed has ruled the Neck beneath the banner
of a black lizard-lion on a grey-green field.
We are not wealthy, powerful, or known even
to our own countrymen.
Our home, Greywater Watch, is no castle you've
ever seen.
And seeing it once does not mean you'll ever
find it again.
For Greywater Watch moves.
Many would-be conquerors have died trying
to find us.
With war all around and our Stark lord besieged
on all sides, many more will doubtless soon
try.
They will look at us on a map and see a stranglehold
for the North.
And they will forget that the sea itself once
entered the Neck and not all of it returned.
Jon Snow: Our lands stretches from the Wall
down to the Neck, a narrow land that divides
it from the rest of Westeros.
Legend has it that the Children of the Forest
flooded it in their war against the First
Men.
If that's true, every Northman owes them a
debt of gratitude.
The swamps of the Neck are as good as the
Wall for keeping out unwelcome armies.
And if the swamps don't deter you, the crannogmen
should.
Small, shy people who rarely leave those swamps
and who follow House Reed, the gatekeepers
of the North, and among the most important
and loyal bannermen of House Stark.
Also a bit strange.
I heard their oath of fealty once as a child.
It's is like no other lords'.
Ancient and dark, they swear by earth and
water, by bronze and iron, and by ice and
fire.